angst vor sich ratlosigkeit und ich
finde wir haben jetzt so viel
faktenbasis und so viel material und so
viel lebenserfahrung dazugewonnen dieser
pandemie dass jetzt das team mut mit dem
themen vernunft geschwindigkeit
aufnehmen muss und mit der gleichen mit
der gleichen begeistert heid mit dem
gleichen schmiss mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit wie wir immer weiter
verschärft haben müssen wir jetzt
lockern lockern lockern es kann auch
nicht langsamer gehen wer jetzt noch auf
maximale sicherheit setzt muss sich mit
dem argument auseinandersetzen aber
vielleicht ein freiheits feindes